What's the worst bug on the planet?
You might vote for the horsefly or perhaps the wasp,...
...but for many people, the worst offender is by far the mosquito.
The buzzing, the biting, the itching.
The mosquito is one of the most commonly detested pests in the world.
But it's not just that mosquitoes are annoying.
They're also deadly.
Mosquitoes can transmit everything from malaria to yellow fever,...
...to West Nile virus to dengue.
Over a million people worldwide die every year from mosquito-borne diseases.
And that's just people.
Horses, dogs, cats, they can all get diseases from mosquitoes too.
So if these bugs are so dastardly, why don't we just get rid of them.
We are humans after all and we're pretty good at getting rid of species.
Well, it's not quite so simple.
Getting rid of the mosquito removes a food source for lots of organisms,...
...like frogs and fish and birds.
Without them, plants will lose a pollener.
But some scientists say that mosquitoes aren't actually all that important.
If we got rid of them, they argue, another species would simply take their place.
And we'd probably have far fewer deaths from malaria.
The problem is that nobody knows what would happen if we killed off all the mosquitoes.
Something better might take their spot or perhaps something even worse.
The question is, are we willing to take that risk?